so I was we were fortunate enough to
meet at the Forbes 30 under conference
last year in Boston I was named a 30
under 30 2017
mo and Melo were both 30 under 30 s for
2018 going into 19 and I shot these guys
an email I knew they were at the event
doing a contrast at hey fellow 30 under
30 I've got this great idea for this
chocolate filled marshmallow idea you're
a human marshmallow we should get
together and talk about it and so at the
event is where all of that started so we
sat down and tried some samples and and
took it from there one of the things
that happens when you get thousands of
30 under 30 alumni all together in the
same conference is that they start
making business deals together and
that's exactly what happened with Mikey
marshmallow and mochi Liese
so Mikey before he founded his existing
consumer packaged goods had this idea
why not create a marshmallow that
already had the chocolate inside so that
when you roast it it melted from the
inside out and you have this perfect
s'more making material marshmallow the
DJ and his manager mo decided that they
loved this idea as well they went into
business together and in true
entrepreneurial form rather than having
a big cash endorsement they worked at an
equity based deal so that marshmallow
has a stake in these marshmallows going
forward I got an a a couple emails from
Mikey and I ignored them and then
finally while I was there he said just
give me one chance I'll meet you were a
hotel lobby I have to show you this idea
I have so I met with them at the lobby
of the hotel we were in so you know at
that time there was no actual product
and we had an offer from another
marshmallow brand on the table
you could tell he had a lot of like
driving passion for this idea he out of
uh creating a stuffed marshmallow and
the idea is so innovative and I think
the whole marshmallow brand has been
built off of an innovation so for us
that's where we decided to you know take
the leap of faith and partner with with
stuff buffs
Mikey's initial success really had
nothing to do with marshmallows
whatsoever it was his existing consumer
packaged goods business that's how he
got on the list
that's what lured him to the accelerator
or rather that's why he was lured to the
accelerator out there in Bethlehem
Pennsylvania which is why we were in
turn lured out there to learn a little
bit more about what he was doing both
with his broader business and with stuff
puffs and marshmallow so about eleven
years ago I had the idea sitting around
a campfire for creating the first what
would become stuff puffs and I
personally didn't really like s'mores
that much I wasn't really into the
conventional set up and I realized my
problem was that the chocolate never
melted and so you'd roast this beautiful
golden toasty melty marshmallow and he'd
put it on this square of ice-cold
chocolate and he'd bite into it and it
would be cold and unsatisfying and so
around this campfire 11 years ago I
peeled a marshmallow apart put a little
square of chocolate inside roast it and
lo and behold it melted from the inside
out I took another four years for me to
actually leave work and go chase this
dream and now seven years after that
we're standing in front of our second
manufacturing facility for a
ribbon-cutting ceremony it's a hundred
and fifty thousand square foot facility
that allows up to about 350 million
dollars for the capacity this is the new
facility here
the current ones in Wisconsin but this
is the new one that they've just built
should be up and running in hopefully
August but yeah this is uh this is a
marshmallow Playhouse you can reach 40%
of Americans in under two days like
truck here in the Lehigh Valley so it's
a great distribution point you've seen
Amazon and Walmart put a big footprints
here in the valley there's a lot of
other food manufacturing FedEx just
moved their biggest ground shipping
location here so a really advantageous
location for Freight which is an
important component of what we do and
the other piece that's that's critical
is our private equity partner Factory is
based here in the Lehigh Valley and so
with their experience in the valley
building manufacturing on top of the
advantageous distribution options it
just made a lot of sense to make this
our home to having a stake in a
marshmallow brand makes a ton of sense
for marshmallow the DJ from the very
beginning he's been all about ownership
so you know the deal with stuff puffs
and with Mike he really kind of mirrors
that kind of philosophy that he and Moe
have been following all along I would
not be surprised for one to see stuff
puff marshmallows with the face of
marshmallow the DJ coming out somewhere
down the line the marshmallow business
already has enough capital coming in
from different directions so I think for
us the whole model that's been built
with marshal has been owning ownership
he's not signed a record label he owns
all of his masters like and that's how
we've built the whole business so I
think this was a you know testament to
that of you know investing in ourselves
and getting behind a product that we
could help launch and build
marshmallow and their whole team have
been great in integrating stuff buffs
not only into their cooking with Melo
series but across their Instagram feeds
their Twitter account other YouTube
music videos from their joy time albums
and it's been such an organic
partnership that we really let them kind
of run with it and wherever they see the
best place to fit it it's really cool
partnership
[Music]